Donald Trump apparently still having a
lot of trouble booking talent form at
his inauguration even some of the acts
that had confirmed that they would
perform there are now dropping out
including the B Street Band a Bruce
Springsteen cover band they said they
would play and now they're backing out a
lot of report a lot of performers have
been asked they've all backed out
Trump must really be scrambling to book
some talent right obviously hey Conan
[Applause]
what is it sir you say Trump needs some
talent for his big day yes that's right
apparently they're getting pretty
desperate for performers great news I do
it
okay I'm sorry sir are you an
entertainer you tell me hit it
[Applause]
[Music]
/ that's plenty terrific
I think that's plenty I think Trump is
probably hoping to land some big
celebrities for his inauguration that's
all big favorite teeth like Jack
Nicholson you can through the you
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you can handle though you can handle too
[Applause]
well that was a great impression but
again this is a big presidential
inauguration so I'm sure that they want
really big talent to perform I get it
here is something every breathing loves
juggling
[Applause]
sir I hate to be the one to break it to
you but I just don't think he'll be
playing at the inauguration this year I
just don't think you will be fine then
here is my inauguration my speech you
and Dora Trump can kiss my
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll take a break we'll be right back
Kathy Griffin's here stick around
[Applause]
you